this day after one of the greatest or
depending upon your preferences when it
comes to watching football worst monday
night football games of all time not a
whole lot of defense but just enough
flashes to add to the scoring and
contribute to the 105 total points that
were tallied by the chiefs and the rams
on monday night one of the all-time
classics third highest scoring game in
nfl history and my favorite stat peter
now in nfl history if you have scored 50
or more points you are 216 and one
thanks to the chief scoring 51 but still
losing last night
yeah and i think you know as as we've
been talking about mike there's so many
different ways to go but i'd like to
give jared goff
uh some credit in this game
um you know he's a guy who early on this
season i know he was on my mvp list i
kind of subbed him out for todd gurley
but think of the great throws that he
has made
in their two in my opinion really
signature wins this year they beat the
kansas city chiefs last night in october
they beat the minnesota vikings or
september was whenever and jared goff
has made some absolutely beautiful drop
in the bucket throw it only where your
receiver can catch it deep downfield
only where his guys can catch it and to
me remember when we were you know at the
beginning of his first year when
when you know that first coaching staff
couldn't do anything with him
and and people are wondering okay you're
gonna get rid of golf and get somebody
else as a matter of fact mike i'll tell
you this one general manager candidate
when they were thinking of making a
clean sweep with jeff fisher
one of the general manager candidates
for the rams told me that he would
seriously consider trading jared goff if
he got the job well i think the rams are
pretty happy with how this turned out
jared goff has been terrific and exactly
what uh what what sean mcvay needs to
run his offense an unemotional
computer at quarterback who can drop
throws
into the arms of brandon cooks and
higbee and woods and those guys 35 and
40 yards downfield because sean mcvay
must have a quarterback who can throw
the ball downfield and drop dimes he has
that in jared goff
and the thing about goff he can do
everything that they need him to do he
can make all the throws he can run when
he needs to run and he's durable for a
guy who looks a little a little spindly
a little wiry right he takes hits and he
keeps getting up he went down a couple
times last night and i thought is he
gonna you know be favoring his shoulder
is he but he he is a guy who can take
that pounding he doesn't take a lot of
it but he takes enough and he makes the
throws and it's just so reliable it's so
steady and for for a team that's in a
city that is founded on flash he is so
unflashy i think it makes it easy to
overlook the guy i mean we get caught up
in todd gurley we get caught up in aaron
donald jared goff is just kind of there
but he's getting it done and you're
right he's he's he's been the perfect
quarterback for sean mcvay's offense and
the contrast between how he was viewed
under jeff fisher and how he's been
viewed the last two years is stark but i
still don't think enough people
appreciate what he can do and the throws
he can make and the things he's doing i
think there's almost this sense that
sean mcvay almost like andy reid andy
reid could turn anybody into a great
quarterback sean mcvay could turn
anybody into a great quarterback so he's
doing it with jared goff but if it
wasn't jared goff it would be somebody
else i feel like that's the attitude
that people have
whether he could or whether he couldn't
you know whether he could make a
quarterback out of chase daniel or or
whoever it doesn't it doesn't matter
nathan peterman nathan peterman yeah
well that would matter
but
but
what i'm saying is that
he's doing it with this guy
and and it i'll never forget a long time
ago mike i was working for a paper
on long island called news day in new
york and
they had me go and do a story because
the giants had just won the super bowl
they had me go and do a story back in
the days when you could travel a lot for
newspapers on what
uh pitfalls face teams when they're
trying to repeat as champions and i'll
never forget i went to interview pat
riley
about the los angeles lakers and how
great they were
and he was so infuriated by this whole
thing ah the coach just has to roll it
out he goes you know in this game
your challenge as a coach is to make
great players greater
and to continue their development as
players and i think that's what sean
mcvay does he gets brandon cooks and he
says we're going to make you better he
gets jared goff who was great at cal he
says we're gonna make you better
and that is what happens i think when
you're coached by a guy like sean mcvay
who's gonna think of things that can
help you get better and that's why in my
opinion he's so significantly better
under sean mcvay than he was
under the staff of jeff fisher
he's currently second in the league with
3547 passing yards third in touchdown
passes with 26 and he's second in yards
per attempt
9.31 that is moving the offense when you
are gaining 9.31 yards every time you
throw the football and look we see the
rams now at 10-1 they had the one loss
on the road against the saints the
saints still have one loss
and it does it come down to is it this
simple is it this easy to say
whoever has home field for the rematch
between the rams and saints is the super
bowl favorite or is there another team
in the nfc that you think could disrupt
what what feels like an inevitable
reunion of those two old nfc west teams
i doubt it mike but you know the bears
are so good on defense their defensive
front
uh is just fantastic
and if khalil mack stays healthy akeem
hicks stays healthy
they're going to be tough to beat the
whole question is
you know are they going to be able to
play offense well enough are they going
to be able to put up enough points
imagine if the bears have to play both
of those teams they got to beat the rams
and the saints to get to the super bowl
that would be the biggest gauntlet a
team has ever
surmounted
to get to the super bowl i mean imagine
you beat the rams and the saints and you
haven't even won the super bowl i mean
that's that's the incredible part of it
but the one thing is i'll just make this
point
do not eliminate especially after
they've turned the ball over a bunch
against the patriots and the rims just
don't eliminate the kansas city chiefs
because
they're good enough
if they don't turn it over
to score 50 and to beat anybody on any
day now again that's a very big if
but because they have turned it over
when they've played their mega games but
i think that andy reid's got a chance to
get this figured out they'll go back
and you know obviously their really big
game down the stretch is chargers
probably with a healthy bosa and with a
formidable defense coming in on a short
week thursday night to play kansas city
in december
and and that will really tell the tale
in my opinion of whether the chiefs can
hold on to home field uh and advance in
the playoffs
yeah chiefs have raiders twice the
ravens the chargers and a trip to
seattle on december 23rd sunday night
football and you know we've been
pointing toward patriots chiefs as an
afc championship game rematch of that
classic from earlier this year ram
saints in the nfc and i keep looking for
teams that could disrupt and peter i
think the seahawks if they end up
matching up with the rams in the
divisional round first they have to get
to the playoffs obviously and then the
seahawks would have to win in the wild
card round but i think the rams want
nothing to do with the seahawks for a
round three after giving up 31 points to
them twice
and i also think a team and this may
sound crazy and there's a chance that it
is i feel like if the cowboys make it
and if the cowboys formula works and you
know chris sims and i talked about this
yesterday
if the cowboy you can tell like in the
first five minutes of a cowboys game
whether they've got a chance to win
because they've got one formula they've
got one plan they've got plan a and
that's it and if plan a is working and
you can and if it's a physicality based
approach on both sides of the ball if
it's working that's the cowboys day and
i could see them if their approach would
work against the rams or the saints i
could see them stunning one of those two
teams because that's what do you think
what's all the hype going to be just
like last year steelers patriots
steelers patriots oh we can't wait for
steelers patriots jaguars had something
to say about it i think that's going to
be the fascinating wrinkle as those four
teams patriots chiefs saints rams start
hovering toward those rematches who's
going to potentially throw that monkey
wrench into the into the plans and i
think the seahawks could do it with the
rams and i think the cowboys could do it
with either of those teams
well there's no question but you have to
be able to play ball control you know
the season that reminds me of that of
dallas's
challenge this year
is the 1990 new york giants remember
when they go to san francisco it might
be the best 49er team of all time uh the
giants play ball control with a strong
running game and jeff hoss stetler at
quarterback they kick five field goals
force a couple of turnovers they beat
the 49ers 15 to 13. they're gonna play
one of the best offensive teams of all
time the buffalo bills in the super bowl
when bill parcells gets on the team bus
at candlestick park after beating the
49ers he looks at his offensive
coordinator ron earhart and he says you
got to play clock ball against the
buffalo bills in other words hold on to
it as long as he can the giants hold on
to it for 41 minutes keep the ball away
from jim kelly thurman thomas andre reed
and they they eke out an ugly ugly
victory so they win the super bowl and
that year
taught me one thing about football
that teams that can play defense teams
that can run and i think it's still true
today and you watch the dallas cowboys
there that's their chance play defense
run it play keep away from the great
offensive teams and you're gonna have a
chance to win any game and you know i
think back to what you said earlier in
the program peter that football has
changed here we are in the aftermath of
a very significantly hyped monday night
football game that delivered 9-1 teams
coming in 54-51
you mentioned giants 49ers before that
championship game that year in 1990 they
had a round one monday night they both
came in ten and one
and that was at the exact opposite
spectrum seven to three was the final
score of that game both of the
quarterbacks stunk because the defenses
were so good so here we are 28 years
later it is completely the opposite way
it's arena football in comparison to
what we saw between the giants and the
49ers back in 1990 but you're absolutely
right
you think about weather now it won't
matter if you're playing indoors in the
superdome but think about kansas city
think about new england outdoors in the
elements you you get some of these teams
out there and if they can control the
clock control the ball and just be
physical you hear that all the time mike
frable told me after the titans beat the
patriots the way to beat the patriots is
be more physical than them in every
phase and make them work for every yard
they gain a team like the cowboys can do
that to these high-powered offenses make
them feel every blade of grass that they
try to advance and and that's why
even though we get caught up in the
great teams there's other teams out
there saying don't forget about us and i
think there's some some folks that could
make things very interesting in january
when we return i want to take up our
question of the day as it relates to a
potential chiefs rams rematch in the
super bowl or would you like to see the
chiefs and the saints get together we'll
let you know what folks are saying about
that when pft live continues
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports